2016 is a crucial year in efforts to end
a civil war in Colombia that has claimed
more than 200,000 lives the government
and the Revolutionary Armed Forces of
Colombia FARC aim to wrap up a peace
accord launched four years ago this week
Amy peas debating next steps sought to
advance the process hemos conseguido una
toe es que CET grupos politico's ke raba
decimos dastan tase en las posiciones
ido logica SI los conceptos por los de
acuerdo en prendido enso lamentos de
mano del presidente santos un proceso
que otros y IDC era que no koku y era y
que por fig parece que las que las
partes quien esta cincuenta y ou Segura
pueden llegar a few crucial day pass a
signatory to a free trade agreement with
Colombia and Peru the EU has plenty at
stake and says one MEP plenty of
responsibility to to ensure commercial
activities support future peace and
human rights las multinationals con
mucha razón europaeus son tambien a grab
on tape or sto alguna Bannion el
conflicto poor poor oporto de esos
conflictos con con respecto a las
tierras yahi gray mas que también la new
europea tendria que actuar mi pais want
to an agreement by march this year
remaining issues include demobilization
of competence and justice and
reparations for victims deals on land
redistribution and combating the drugs
trade have already been reached
you